lothar wieder der chef des robert koch
institut hat seinen job gemacht jetzt
haben wir wieder das weihnachts
warnungen das war ganz ganz klar er hat
sich eindringlich als drei mal
unterstrichen quasi in der lautstärke in
der tonalität und dreimal wiederholt
eindringlich gewarnt
feiern sie nur im familienkreis reisen
sie nicht treffen sie sich wenn
überhaupt noch mit anderen menschen dann
immer mit den gleichen leuten und wenn
dann am besten draußen denn das virus so
wieder lebt von unseren kontakten und
wir machen erst in virus immer noch zu
einfach die lage ist weiter dramatisch
und sie verschlechtert sich weiter
also hat ein beispiel genannt in der 2
in der zweiten dezemberwoche sind
deutschlandweit 3000 menschen an oder
mit dem corona virus gestorben man weiß
inzwischen dass die meisten die mit dem
corona virus gestorben sind dass es da
auch einen tatsächlichen zusammenhang
gibt das gibt es inzwischen auch aus aus
studien
das heißt dass in jedem deutschen
landkreis in einer einzigen woche zehn
menschen gestorben sind in jedem
landkreis das ist das machst dann mal
ein bisschen klassischer wir haben in
deutschland knapp 300 landkreise das
macht pro landkreis pro woche zehn tote
erzählen wir mal die woche durch also es
ist nicht wenig was da momentan dann
stirbt und er hat auch klargemacht wo
die meisten leute sterben und wo die
meisten ausbrüche sind und das sind nach
wie vor deutschlands altenheime und da
sollte man ja glauben dass wir in
deutschland nicht so schlecht dastehen
wie irgendwie andere staaten mal zum
vergleich wir haben uns ja immer ein
bisschen lustig gemacht und ein bisschen
uns erhoben über die usa unter donald
trump in dieser krise die
sterblichkeitsrate in deutschland nähert
sich im moment dramatischen der der usa
an
also wieder ist die lücke nur noch so
kleinen der abstand zu anderen ländern
relativ groß da stehen wir momentan
richtig mies da das liegt daran wie bei
uns in den altenheimen sich das virus
ausbreiten kann die wenig schutz dort
vorhanden ist und fahren vor allem
vorhanden war
das ist dramatisch und da auch sein
sender pay also bitte bitte nicht reisen
nicht mit so vielen leuten treffen und
zu hause bleiben und solange er zuerst
gesagt so lange wie noch leute in dem
kanzler werk oder woanders in köln oder
in hamburg oder egal wo im partykeller
oder im wintergarten noch feiern so
lange machen jetzt den virus zu einfach
und da war jetzt die ganz große sorge
heraus führen dass das auch über
weihnachten sich dramatisch verändern
kann noch mal dramatisch verschlechtern
kann dass der effekt den man eigentlich
den doktor haben will
dann erst nach und nach weihnachten
erstmals schlimmer wird das erst mal
schlimmer dann wie ein riesen zeitverzug
haben mit einer besserung
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren